>>Ray: Welcome to Faster Apps, Faster Apps
Faster. I hope you guys had a good lunch and
you're, you're ready to process some information
about the GWT compiler. So, my name is Ray
Cromwell and I work on the GWT compiler for
the GWT team.
And one of the things I hope to show you today
is how the GWT compiler works, how it actually
makes your job script faster and smaller,
and then to maybe give you a couple of tips
about how to help, help the compiler along
a little bit. And then we'll talk about how
to make your builds faster.
So, if you want to follow along, there is
a bitly link for you: bit.ly/io2010-gwt2.
That will be a Google Wave where there's live
note taking and I think you can ask some questions
there. So, as I said, there's going to be
two things covered in this presentation.
One is --is-- building faster Apps; how the
GWT compiler actually helps y-, your Apps
execute faster, load faster and so on. So,
I'll get into the details of the compiler
in a way, maybe, that it hasn't been explained
before.
And the second part is I'll try to help you
actually speed up your compilation so that
you're waiting less for your builds to actually
happen.
So, here's the inspiration for this. I don't
really think I need to preach to the choir
too much, but, latency matters and if you
saw Kelly--
[phone rings]
Uh-oh. I have call there. If you saw Kelly's
presentation on Speed Tracer earlier, you
really know how much latency matters, but
there's a monetary reason why as well. Amazon
actually presented at a Web conference last
year and reported that for every hundred milliseconds
of latency they lost one percent in sales;
that's real money.
Likewise, Google actually did a focus group
study of people using their browser and they
found out for every 500 milliseconds of latency
it takes for the search results page to come
back, they would lose 20 percent of their
traffic. That's, that's huge.
So, we definitely want to speed up the rate
at which your Apps can load in and return
results to the user. And GWT helps a lot with
that. So, here's an example, if you were a
user who started out in 2006 on GWT 1.3, and
all you did was simply recompile your application,
you made no other changes to your code, just
downloaded the new SSDK and recompiled it,
your JavaScript got 30 percent smaller.
So, you di--, you didn't have to do any work
at all. And I think that's, that's pretty
good. And what we've done over time is we've
continued to iterate on the GWT compiler and
tried to make the code smaller and faster
so that all you have to do is simply update
to later versions of the compiler and we make
your Web App just run faster.
[clears throat]
Here's another measurement. This is between
GWT 1.7 and GWT 2.0 startup time lengths.
See how fast it takes for your App to first
show to the user. And this graph is kind of
hard to read, but, GWT 1.7 is represented
as a 1.0 factor.
On Safari, if y-, if you recompile with GWT
2.0, the speedup was 2.5. So, that means the
latency went down by a factor of 2.5. So,
if it was a 250 millisecond start, it went
down to a hundred milliseconds. Likewise,
for Firefox, the, the improvement wasn't so
dramatic but it did get a factor of 1.25 improvement.
So, with that said, let's talk about what
the GWT compiler is. So, a lot of people,
they're not r-, really sure what it is, they
just think, "Ok, it translates Java to JavaScript,
maybe it maps a Java method directly to a
function, declaration in JavaScript. It's
just a straight one-to-one translation." And
actually, it's not.
The GWT compiler is a totally classical compiler
just like your C compiler or your Pascal compiler
and things like that. It aggressively optimizes
the code; really changes it and moves it around
a lot. Moreover, it actually produces multiple
executables. So, it's kind of like a cross-compiler.
Like if you were cross-compiling for x86 and
ARM, only the target platforms are not two
different CPUs; their two different browsers,
or mobile, or different locales like Chinese
or some German.
And just like your C compiler, it now has
a linker so there's additional steps you can
do with the artifacts that are produced with
the compiler, like repackaging them for different
things, like, let's say you wanted to install
a GWT application as an Android application
and it appears on a menu. You can write a
linker for that.
So, here are some of the core concepts of
the compiler. One of the most important ones
is this thing we call permutations. So, basically,
the compiler has the capability, as it's compiling,
based on rules that you write, to basically
search and replace classes.
So, maybe you've got a class and you called
it "payment service". Well, maybe you went
through GWT compiler, replace that for different
patterns. Maybe on Android you want to use
protocol buffers and on GWT you want to use
RPC or something. Well, the compiler can do
that and it's called wh--, what we call Differed
Binding. So, it's the ability to do dependency
injection at the compile time instead of runtime.
And the interesting this is, is that after
the replacements are done, the compiler looks
at the, all the permutations that have been,
had the substitutions done. And for every
unique substitution it does a separate compilation.
So, you get a different executable in a sense.
Here's the more famous example, it's in the
gwt-log user library. So, GWT has this class
called DOM, which delegates the DOMlmpl. And
DOMlmpl basically knows how to do things like
a append childs; shows them to the DOM to
create elements that attach to event listeners
and so on. How, it's the API for manip--,
interfacing with the browser. But, because
different browsers, as you know, have different
ways of interacting, like IE uses a attachEvent
every other browser uses addListener, addEventListener.
You need different implementations of that.
In the traditional way it's done, in most
AJAX libraries is you have like a test. You
say, like, if element.@attachEvent, then it's
the IE version and if it's alt it's the HTML5
version. And that means that when you send
your application to a Firefox user, it's got
all this IE code in there that's never executed.
It's just tested for but not run.
What we're doing with GWT compiler is say,
"Look, when the compiler is compiling the
thing, if you're going to, if you're compiling
for IE, let's just only include the classical
DOMlmpl IE or DOMlmpl IE8, which enclose all
the IE specific versions of those methods
and if then if you're on Firefox or WebKit,
let's substitute in a, a special version for
those." In which case, you're producing now
two or more executables; one for each browser.
But, their smaller because each one doesn't
have to know about the browser's edge cases.
So, but, there's more to this than just that.
What this does, actually, is it permits the
compiler to make better optimizations. So,
for example, if you had a class called "Animal"
and had two subclasses, "Cat" and "Dog", and
let's say in the Safari browser you instantiate
a "Cat" and in IE's you instantiate a "Dog".
Well, what happens is the compiler c-, when
it compiles these two separate permutations,
only one of the classes is in-, instantiated
in each. So, the way the compiler sees it
is, "An Animal is always a Cat. There's no
type of other animal than a Cat."
And likewise in the other browsers. So, it's
actually permits the compiler to replace all
those polymorphic method calls that may be
overwritten with just a direct Inline call
to a "Cat" method.
[clears throat]
So, that's sort of the preliminary, we get
that out of the way.
Here are the major phases of the compiler.
So, there's five of them. So, the first one
is called precompile. So, what precompile
does is, is it basically looks at the source
code in text form that's on your disk, sucks
it all into the compiler and creates intermediate
data structures, like abstracts and text trees.
And then hands it off to another phase or,
as you'll see later, it can actually send
it out to a network where it can be distributed,
you can build it in a distributed build. So
that phase doesn't do much except for like,
parsing and some other fix-ups.
The next phase that's more important, that's
the Java optimization phase. This is basically
where the compiler is saying, "I know about
Java. I know particular things about the Java
Type System, so I'm going to do optimizations
based on what I know about Java." But, of
course, there are some things in, in a JavaScript
application that a Java Optimizer wouldn't
know about, like closures, function redefinitions,
property lookups, and things like that. They
just don't exist in Java.
So, there's a separate JavaScript optimization
phase that wor--, works on a JavaScript AST.
This phase actually does what many of you
might be familiar with what's called code-splitting
in GWT 2.0.
Finally, after you take that Java script and
you do, build optimizations on it, you have
to get it back to text on the J-, on the,
as a .js file. So, when you serialize it out,
this text, you want to do minification and
obfuscation and all kinds of compressions.
So, there's actually optimizations that we
do purely on the text alone, like we don't
even know what the code is, we're just doing
actual text transformations and I'll show
you some of that later.
Finally, there's the linking stage that I
mentioned earlier which is how you package
it all up, yeah. So, let's go on to talk about
Java optimizations. So, there's many more
than this, but these are some of the most
important ones. The first one is called "type
tightening".
Second one's called c-, what we call "converting",
we call "statification", it's sort of a mouth
full. It's converting non-overwritten methods
to static methods. Finalizing, pruning and
dead code elimination and method call inlining.
So, type tightening, what is it? So, before
I use the example of, of subtyping "animal"
into separate permutations, but even if in
one permutation you have two classes, sometimes
the compiler can reason that there's only
ever one that's going to be used in a particular
circumstance.
So, here we have "Animal" and it has a "Cat"
and a "Dog" subclass. And you have a method,
you have a, an assignment here which is "Animal
a = new Cat();" If "Dog" is never instantiated
by newCall in this method or in any other
method, the compiler will say, "Well, look,
I know no one ever created the 'Dog', so I'll
just change that left-hand side of the equation
to be a 'Cat' type." Likewise, there's a method
there called "public static Dog getAnimal()",
right? So the return type of this method is
always a "Dog". So, if you were to say "Object
o = getAnimal();" the compiler will say, "Well,
hey, that thing always returns a 'Dog', so
let me fix up the type on the left-hand side
to a tighter bound." Right? That's why we
call it type tightening. And this helps a
lot when we get to inlining.
So, status-, staticifying methods, this is
kind of a hard thing to pronounce, it, basically
what this does, is here you have two methods
in "Animal." One is "public String toString()"
and it returns a name field, and it's not
overridden in any subclasses. The next method
is "public void speak() " and
this one is overridden in the "Cat" subclass.
So, since the compiler knows that "toString"
is never overridden, it's fundamentally not
polymorphic. So, the compiler can say, "Ok,
well I'm gon--, actually just take that off
the object and make it a global top-level
function." And the result is what you see
at the bottom, which is "public static String
toString", and now what would normally be
the "this pointer" for the object is passed
in as an argument.
And this has a lot of benefits, for example,
like a, top-level functions actually tend
to execute faster and, in Chrome V8, so there's
some JavaScript VM things going on. But also,
it actually allows the compiler to inline
it because since it's not polymorphic it actually
knows that there's only one method 'toString'
for animal types, ever. It doesn't matter
if it's a "Cat" or a "Dog", whatever; it's
always "X.name". So, it just will inline it
as "X.name".
So, finalizing, sort of an addendum to that,
we notice that a method is never overridden,
a class is never subclassed, or a variable
is never reassigned. We'll just change it
to be final-, we'll use a "final" qualifier
for that. And that helps the compiler out
because if it knows, let's say a constant,
like "X = 10" is final, then later on when
there's a reference back to that variable,
it can just go, "Wow, that thing's never been
assigned a different value. It's just a constant."
So, it can actually just replace a later reference
with 'X' with the actual number, thereby eliminating
the variable assignment.
So, pruning by far, is the most important
thing in a GWT compiler. And basically, it
works like code garbage collection. What we
do is we start out at the entry point of your
program and we trace through in the compiler.
And we determine every possible bit of reachable
code that could ever be touched by executing
the program from the entry point.
And when we do that, at the end we have a
collection of what's called the "live" methods,
the live fields, the live classes; everything
else, we just throw away. So, the result of
this is if you're using GWT and you're using
a bunch of libraries or whatever, you usually
don't pay for code you don't use. You could
have, you know, 500K of libraries and you
call one method, you don't incur the costs
of compiling all that JavaScript into your
output application.
Dead Code Elimination is a phase of the GWT
compiler that's, I think it's somewhat poorly
named, it really should be called Static Evaluation
or Compile Time Evaluation, because what it
does is it looks at the code and says, "If
there's some piece of code that I know just
by looking at it that I could replace it with
the answer of evaluating that at compile time,
then I'll do it."
So, for example, if you had an expression
like, "false && expression" the compiler can
just go, "That's always false." Because the
right hand side will never be evaluated so
it'll just replace the, the left hand side
with "false". Or, maybe you have "if (false)"
so you have, like, "if (debug)" and "debug"
is a variable somewhere and you have a bunch
of debug code, if you declare that at the
top-level of your program as like, "debug
= false", the compiler will just make all
those debugging statements go away.
Constant folding, if you're doing a bunch
of string concatenation, every time there's
two constants that are side by side, the compiler
will just go ahead and add those together
so it won't incur any runtime costs for string
concatenation.
Likewise, with numbers, and there's just a
whole bunch more that it does. It can convert
post fix ops that are never assigned into
pre fix. That might not seem very important,
but it turns out that it helps out the JavaScript
JITs a lot when they're doing a bunch of increments,
like a loop. Constant propagation I kind of
already covered.
[clears throat]
And here's an example of what you get. So,
last year, I pr-, presented this library called
"GWT Query" which was a reimplementation of
jQuery in GWT. And the library is actually
about 300 kilobytes of Java Source on disk.
Here, I've gzipped it to make the comparisons
fair, but the source code of this library
is 50KB gzipped. And I wrote a sample application
that applies a bunch of progressive enhancement
to a page, but I only use a couple of the
functions in the GWTware library, like 'alt3'
CSS or doing ":hover" or something like that.
The result, the resulting application compressed
is 780 bytes. So the compiler threw away 99.99
percent of that code. So all you're left with
is a couple of Inline functions that actually
got called. And you don't tend to get this
situation when using Java-, through JavaScript
because you don't tend to know ahead of time
what methods were gonna be called so you actually
have to strip down the entire JS with all
the functions because you don't know ahead
of time.
But, because we have a compile step, the compiler
gets to see all of the code that is expected
to be sent to the user ahead of time. So,
it can actually make that determination.
Here's another example. This is of a graph
showing that, how big your application will
be as you start to call more methods in the
GWT Widget library. So, you start out with
nothing, you get this little empty one down
there. I know this chart's kind of hard to
see, but it's not really relevant what those
bottom axes labels are, but basically, each
one of them is another widget you're using;
text box, tree, and so on. And as you add
each widget, the size of the application output
goes up a little bit.
But, as you can see, it tapers off because
there's a lot of code sharing that happens
between widgets that use the same base class,
they use the same java.util.Collections. So,
it doesn't grow without bound, but if you
want to actually make a small application,
you can. You just have to be a little bit
careful about what methods or what widgets
you're going to use. And that's what I did
in jQuery.
So, Method Inlining. So this is, is another
really important optimization in GWT. And
what it basically does is what it says. If
you see a function, like "addTip(float bill,
float rate)" and it has an expression, "(return
bill*(1+rate);)" and the compiler can actually
determine what the target method is, like
it's not overridden by five different limitations.
It will just take the parameters that you
see at the call site and substitute them for
the actual variables in the body of the method
and then replace that at the call site. So,
you see that the "addTip(100,Of, O.2f);" becomes,
after inlining, "100*(1+0.2f)". But then,
because of that dead code elimination phase,
the compiler goes, "Hey, everything there
is constant." So it actually just rewrites
that as the answer, which is just 120. So,
if this was a real application, it, well you
can see is actually the addTip method got
totally eliminated. It never even made it
in the download to the user.
The Java Method Inliner is not perfect; it
actually has a lot of restrictions, but some
of those are for good reason. It does three
things really well. One is, is that it reduces
most of the Java getter/setter calls. So,
when you tend to program in Java, you tend
to have property getters and setters.
And the Inliner definitely will eliminate
almost all of those because they're usually
not overridden and they're usually small.
It tries to avoid bloating the code, though.
So if the method is more than a couple of
lines long it won't inline it because it will
tend to make the JavaScript bigger and that's
one of the main things you want to guard against.
Finally, it enables optimization stages to
work better. So, for example; if you've got
like one method and it's calling another method;
it's gonna pull that other method in to this
method and then the compiler kind of has more
context to see when it's tracing to the code,
what's being, what's depending on what, so
it can eliminate more because maybe there's
some dead code in there that got pulled in.
So, after it's finished with the JavaScript
optimization stage, it goes on to do-, sorry,
the Java optimization, it goes on to do the
Java optimization. So, it takes the Java code
that's optimized and it dumps it into a JavaScript
data structure. And then it performs many
of the same optimizations, so static evaluations,
like the same things you saw for like constant
expression elimination and so on; it does
it in JavaScript as well because there are
probably some things it didn't catch like
variables that came in from JSOs and things
like that.
That, the compiler, the Java part of the compiler
does not know about JavaScript so it can't
do that part of the work. The Inliner is also
in there and there's a reason why you want
to have a JavaScript Inliner is because JSNI
methods don't get inlined by the Java part
of the c-, because it doesn't know about JavaScript
methods.
Likewise, if you have like a method that has
a closure in it, you can't really inline it
because the closure wi--, captures the scope
of where it's declared. And if you, if you
basically inline the body into another scope,
you've, you've changed the meaning of the
code.
Unused Function Remover is like a pruning
and code splitting, of course, people have
probably heard of if you're a GWT user. I
kind of already covered the JavaScript Inliner.
So, but here is the result. This is the part
of the thing you're more interested in. So,
when you do --do-- inlining, although V8 and
Nitro and many of the other JavaScript engines,
and like TraceMonkey, and whatever, we're
getting pretty good at this. They’re still
not perfect.
So, when a compiler does inlining it still
actually help the performance of these advanced
JavaScript VMs. In this case, what we have
here is a demonstration of capability detection
versus polymorphic versus inline. What this
means is let's say you had some particular
piece of code that had to run differently
on different browsers.
So, in IE, maybe you did like, "if element.attachEvent,
then some bit of code, else, some bit of code
for Firefox, and so on." Another way you could
do that, of course, is you can make a different
object and have it overridden for IE and have
it overridden for Firefox, like, you know,
attach element as a method on something. That's
the polymorphic case.
And the third case is inlining. And so you
can see the difference between capability
detection and polymorphic is not that different
on the ma-, the modern browsers. But actually,
when the compiler inlines these things, it,
it results in a ten percent performance improvement.
And there's a more dramatic example of this.
Kelly Norton, who did the Measure to Milliseconds
talk earlier, ported the Suns-, the SunSpider
browser benchmarks from JavaScript to Java
and let the GWT compiler have at it. And this
is the result. GWT is in yellow and the JavaScript
version is in blue on the same browser. And
you can see there's some dramatic performance
improvements in some of these benchmarks,
purely because of the optimizations I outlined
earlier.
So, GWT produces code that usually can be
made actually smaller than what you write
by hand, but actually it produces faster code
and that's the more important thing.
[clears throat]
This is probably a, an even better one. This
is Gwt Query. It's my jQuery port, so I rewrote
the CSS Selector Engine that jQuery has in
Java for GWT. And then I let GWT have at it.
This is a comparison of Prototype, Dojo, jQuery,
and GwtQuery on the slickspeed CSS Selector
benchmark that they all use. And as you can
see, Prototype came in at about 3,800 milliseconds,
Dojo was about 1,200, jQuery was about 600,
and GwtQuery was about 400. So, GWT basically
produced code faster than the best JavaScript
Ninja's in the industry could produce by hand.
And I think that's, the, a something to say.
So, after you've done JavaScript optimizations,
--
[pause]
we have to get it on disk so it can be sent
back to your browser. And we call; this is
the text based optimizations part of the browser.
So, the first thing we're going to do, is
we're going to take that tree in memory of
the JavaScript program and we're gonna serialize
it, the text. But as we're serializing it,
we can remove all extraneous whitespace, semicolons
and parenthesis and so on. So, a common thing,
of course, and I didn't even know this until
I started doing this, but like, you can leave
off parenthesis when you're calling JavaScript
constructors that don't take arguments.
So, if you have "newFoo( )" you can actually
change this to "newFoo", without the parenthesis.
That actually dropped the size of GWT applications
by about one percent. And that's a pretty
good improvement for such a small change.
The compiler also knows a lot about the JavaScript
language and the precedence of operators.
So, if someone accidentally put extra parenthesis
around an expression like, "a+(b*c)" because
they w-, weren't sure whether or not "a+b"
was going to be evaluated first. The compiler
will go ahead and just remove that. But the
next stage of course is, is, is, is more important.
The compiler per-, performs a aggressive obfuscation
far more than y-, you'll get in like YUI Compressor,
or any of the other JavaScript libraries.
And the reason why it can do that is because
it knows every single method that will ever
be called from the start of your program.
So, it knows whether it's public, private,
who's using it and so on. And so it's free
to totally rename everything, and I mean everything.
A lot of the other minifiers don't because
they're not sure if a given method like, "createWidget",
or whatever, "createSlider" is actually going
to be called from outside the library or whether
it's an internal function only.
So, the compiler knows a lot more information
about what's actually called. So, pretty much
in a GWT program, when it's actually compiled
and it's on disk, there's almost none of the
original identifiers are present and everything
is changed into one or two character variable
names.
The interesting thing though, is when you
do this to a GWT program and you look at the
output, you'll see a lot of functions that
look identical. Like, like functions duplicated
over and over again, like dozens. And you're
saying like, "Why, why are there, why would
someone write the same function like ten times?"
And it turns out that what happens is --is--
that every setter method or getter method
you write, after its obfuscated, will tend
to look identical.
So, if you had like on a employ object, let's
say you had "setFirstName" and it was saying,
"This.FirstName=something." And then on, like,
a car object you had "set.ModelYear", you
know, "This.ModelYear=something." Well, after
you compile those and obfuscate them, they
look identical. They both say, "This.X=Y"
after obfuscated because they get the same
identifiers assigned because they're just
methods so we give them a first available
letter, which might be A or B or C, so you
have like, you know, "This.A=B" or something.
So, because you can do-, w-, because that's
actually, the compiler does this, we just
simply do a simple search and replace.
So, what we do is we say, we take everything
method body and we just store it aside and
compute a hash of it and when we're about
to emit another method, we check to see if
it's already been emitted. And if it already
is, then instead of emitting that r-, method
the same, a second time we just emit a reference
to the first one.
So --as a-- as a result, if you have let's
say 20 beans in your application, the first
field assignment property setter will be the
one function for all 20 of them. It'll just
be a static method that just applies to the
bean. Likewise, for the second and so on.
So, it, it, it actually th--, it reduces the
output size by about two to five percent depending
on how many property setters and getters you
have.
Finally, and this is probably a, a, an interesting
one, I was doing some research on trying to
make gzip work better, like, how can I tweak
the output of the compiler so that the compression
ratio goes up? And it turns out that there
are actually some things you can do. If you
take the code and you sort it such that functions
that only differ by a few characters are closer
together in the output. Then the gzip algorithm,
when it's searching backwards in the program
to look for a match w-, when it's doing it's
compression, so it, it actually can find it
easier because it gives up after a window
of like, eight to thirty-two KB.
So, if your application is like 100K and it,
there's a function called "Foo", and it's
looking backwards for another one that's similar
to "Foo" so it can compress the two together,
if, if it's further back in the file than
eight KB or thirty-two KB, it gives up so
it never sees the other one it could have
used for better compression. So, you simply
bring the com-, the, the functions that are
similar closer together in the output file,
it boosts the compression efficiency.
And there are some other reasons why that
happens too, but the-, they're, they're more
complicated. But, he-, here's an example if
you had something like "BAT CAT RAT BAT CAT
RAT BAT CAT RAT" and we re-, simply reordered
those and there's, let's re-, those represented
functions, simply reordered those so it's
"BAT BAT BAT CAT CAT CAT RAT RAT", you see
that the, the redundancy is more clear to
the compressor. And this, when I implement
this --it-- in some cases it's a, maybe a
one or two percent compressency increase,
but I've seen it go up to 15 percent better
gzip compression. So, it depends on the application,
but it's kind of a unique thing that the GWT
Compiler does.
[clears throat]
So, that's it for how GWT works in terms of
the optimizations. What I wanted to, to talk
about here was to give you some advice on
how to change your code so that the compiler
would work a little better. But, on second
thought, when I started thinking about it,
actually don't want to do that because it's
our job to not hamper your coding style to
fit the compiler.
It's our job to make the compiler better so
that you can just code the way you want for
maximum productivity. So, rather than give
you a bunch of micro-optimizations, I just
wanted to, I just want to give you some general
principles here.
One is, because of that static evaluation,
the thing I showed you earlier where if you
have like, "if(False)" it just eliminates
code, one of the best things you can do is
if you have some bit of code that maybe only
runs on one browser or runs in one locale
or runs, let's say, in debugging mode versus
production mode, you can put it behind a guard.
In this case, I'm using a logging example.
So, let's see how you want to log, you want
to do some logging code. If you put it behind
something like, "if(Log.isLoggingEnabled())",
then what you can do is use the deferred binding
mechanism I talked about earlier where the
compiler can substitute the implementation.
And you can have a subset in your debug permutation,
the compiler will replace that log class with
one where "isLoggingEnabled" returns "True".
So the compiler will not eliminate the debug
code in that c-, in that compile.
But, for the production version, you could
substitute a version where it returns "False",
in which case, if you went to town on logging
statements and you've got like hundreds or
thousands of logging statements all in your
program, this is all go away. And none of
it shows up in your production case. So, that's
one, that's one tip. The other, the other
thing is, in general, if you do have code
that's intended specifically for different
locales and browsers you do use differed binding
mechanism; read up on it.
So, static initializers are a potential source
of problem. How many people kn--, know what
a static initializer is? I just wanna get
some hands, yes. So, if you have a static
field on a class, you know that when you reference
the class the compiler, well, the Java VM
has, is basically already run the initializer
that you might have had on that class. Like
if you had like, "static HashMap=newHashMap()",
right?
Well, the compiler has to ensure that if you
ever call like, "object.HashMap", you reference
that field. It has to make sure that initializer
was called first. So, the GWT Compiler has
to be faithful for those, to those semantics
in Java. And the way it does that is --is--
whenever you have a static method and you
call it from another part of your GWT code,
GWT will insert another function call in front
of your call at the call site, which is called
cl-init which will ensure that first it called
that initialization to set up that field before
the method is allowed to execute.
And the second time it, it, it's called, of
course it won't in-, it won't do the initializer.
It's kind of like it will check to see if
it's already been initialized and then won't
do it. But, that bit of code is always there.
So, every time you call a method, first it's
going to check that field got set up and if
it didn't, it leaves it alone, but its still
"bloat".
So, my advice would be is that, stay away
from sing-, well, not use singletons, but
be careful when you use singletons and static
fields and opt for objects and lazy evaluation
where you can, it tends to help you out a
little bit.
In general, if you keep methods small and
functional, by small I mean it's just a few
lines long and by functional I mean they don't
mutate much, or they don't mutate anything
at all. So, like they just kind of take the
parameters, perform some kind of computation,
and return it. The compiler will be able to
do a better job because it can reason better
about pure, pure functional code than about
code that mutates a bunch of stuff all over
the program.
And finally, use code splitting. So, code
splitting is too complex for me to go into
in this presentation, so I hope everybody
is aware of it. But, code splitting can dramatically
reduce the size of you application. For instance,
for Google Wave, it reduced it by a very significant
factor, from like a megabyte application to
like 100K for like the start-up.
[clears throat]
Ok, so, here are some tips that you can do
that don't rely on you changing your code.
Its tips that you can do that you can tweak
the compiler to make the applets smaller.
So, in GWT 2.0, we introduced this new thing
called Stack Stripping. So, GWT 2.0 had this
ability to turn on stack emulation traces
for IE6, wh--, this is basically like if you
get an exception thrown in JavaScript, we
will actually show you a Java stack trace.
So you'll actually be able to know where to
go in your code to find out what caused the
problem on IE.
On other browsers actually, on like Crome,
WebKits and so on, they actually have some
built-in stack trace functionality. But, this
relies on the fact of keeping the original
function symbol names in the source code because
otherwise, you won't know what the function
is, be called like, "Function X." So, what
was added was this new thing called the stack
stripping mode, if you turn on stack stripping
mode, what it does is, it tries to rename
as many functions as possible in your program
to anonymous functions, meaning they have
no identifier at all. Just like, "Function
open closed parenthesis." And the benefit
of that is --is-- that it frees up the obfuscated
identifier table.
So, you know the compiler is trying to assign
one or two character names to everything to
make your JavaScript as small as possible
so for every function that's able to change
to an anonymous function, that's another extra
identifier that can be used somewhere else
for a variable name. So, it actually tends
to reduce the code by about a milli--, five
percent, depending on how many methods can
be anonymized.
Another thing the GWT compiler does is it
tries to faithfully allow you to call things
like the Java line class .getName method and
.getPackage and so on. So, most people don't
need to do, because GWT doesn't allow dynamic
classes, so most people don't need to access
the Java line class method because class,
class class.
Because we don't have reflection and things
like that at runtime. So, you can, for production,
you can turn on this flag called "-XdisableClassMetadata",
and if you do that the compiler, basically,
doesn't even keep the names of classes around
in your program. It basically just renames
every possible class to be like, class one,
class two, class three. That also significantly
reduces the size of the program.
Finally, a lot of the semantics that people
use debugging GWT applications like getting
class cast exceptions or array store exceptions
and things like that, are not needed for production
now because the production user's not going
to know what to do with it anyway. If, you
know, you sent-, some guys reading Gmail and
he gets a class cast exception, what's he
going to do with it, right? So, you can, you
can add this parameter called "-XdisableCastChecking"
and the compiler will remove all of the runtime
cl-, cast checks all throughout the program,
making it smaller.
So, if you're using GWT RPC, there's a relatively
hidden cl-, module that not many people know
about called Remote Service Obfuscate Tightenings.
So, when you perform a RPC call in GWT to
the server, you know it serializes your Java
classes on the client site and sends them
to the server and vice versa. So, when it's
communicating with the server it has to tell
it, "Hey, this is an employ object. This is
a array list object." And so on.
It has to say what the names of the types
are sending over the wire. But it actually
doesn't need to have them be the same names
that they are in the server side VM. So, if
you turn this on, it will actually obfuscate
the actual names of the types that are being
sent over the wire. And this is actually for
two things.
One is it will make the RPC payload smaller
and it will make the actual code of the GWT
applications smaller. But, two, for security
reasons, you might have some classes on your
server site that you don't want to expose
to the client. So, this will actually we-,
make it so these don't show up in the RPC
payloads. If you have adopted GWT 2.0 and
you've started to use UiBinder and ClientBundle,
you know that there is the ability to have
GWT actually compile and apply optimizations
to CSS style sheets.
You can minimize and combine properties, it
can collapse combinators in CSS and all kinds
of like, useful things. But, it actually can
obfuscate class names and a lot of other things
as well, too. Because if you turn on this
property, GWT will get a lot more aggressive
about how it obfuscates all your CSS class
names. So, it's relatively useful if you're
using like, UiBinder or ClientBundles.
When all else fails and your application is
still too large and you want to make it a
little bit smaller, one of the first things
you could do is try to eliminate RPC. RPC
does tend to add some bloat to your application
and you've got a backend that's written in
an old language like PHP or Python or so on,
and using JSON for your pailer, or you're
willing to use JSON, moving from RPC to JSON
can buy you some space. Likewise, you can
use a thin client library like GWTQuery. Instead
of using GWT Widgets, you progressively enhance
things like you would do if you were doing
JavaScript.
There are some upcoming optimizations this
year that should be, make the GWT Compiler
a lot better. We're making the Inliner a lot
smarter about what it can do, what can be
inlined. So, you're codes should get a little
bit faster and hopefully a little bit smaller.
There's a totally new optimization framework
that's being put into the compiler called
GFlow.
It's a new data flow optimization framework
which some of the most sophisticated C compilers
are using. So, this will allow us to do a
lot of amazing stuff like a, object field
inlining, so we, so we can do things like
if you have an iterator over a collection
we can change that into a for loop and get
rid of the iterator object in Java and just
make it like, "for(i=1-10) on an array list.
So, the iterator can just go bye-bye.
eNom optimizations. So, if you've used eNom
in Java, a lot of people have complained that
they tend to add bloat because each value
object in an eNom, the way Java translates
it, becomes a separate subtype of the eNom.
It's like a separate class. So, if you've
got an eNom that's got a hundred values in
it, you kind of have a hundred class declarations
in your output. And that's not really that
good. Especially if the eNom's only being
used as sort of a type safe number, in a sense.
Or like you're passing, you don't use it in
a switch case statement.
So, some of the new optimizations we're doing
is things like, we detect this and we eliminate
the eNom and just turn it into an integer
from one to ten. So, we replace all the eNoms
with just numbers. But, our end goal is to
dramatically reduce the weight and cost of
the Java runtime environment that's used by
GWT. And hopefully, that will be coming to
a GWT compiler near you and, in the future
this year.
So, that covers the compiler and that's sort
of quite a lot to take on. But, all of this
stuff comes at a cost, so if you've, you were
a JavaScript programmer or maybe you adopted
GWT, you might have realized that your compiles
are taking longer. You're, you know, things
are kind of, you're waiting around, you, you're
checking your Twitter account while the compile
is running and there's a reason for that.
It's not because we don't realize that the
compile has gotten slow over the years.
The reason why it's like that is because we
started out focusing on latency; on the performance
for the end-user. So, we looked at things
and we said, "If we can make the application
five percent smaller, we can shave off like
a couple milli-- hundred milliseconds off
the start-up or something like that, but it
takes you an extra 30 seconds to compile it;
we're going to do it. And you should, you
should not be, feel too bad about it because
look, you're spending 30 seconds of your own
time compiling it, but, a million of your
users are getting back a hundred milliseconds
of their time." So, it's, it's, it's a good
trade-off for your end users because those
are the ones who are paying the bills.
However, we do realize that it kind of impacts
your productivity a little bit. But, in most
cases, if you're a hardcore GWT developer,
you're probably using, or if not, you should
be using DevMode because that will reduce
most of your compile-edit-debug cycle to about
one to two seconds.
The problem is that if you're in a larger
organization, not everybody is going to be
using the GWT tool chain. For example, you
might be building a GWT application that's
kind of like a portlet that's part of a larger
enterprise dashboard or larger application,
in which case, some guy is editing JavaScript
or CSS off in the corner is waiting for a
continuous integration build of the GWT compiler
to get, like, the latest stuff so he can copy
it over and run it. So, not everybody who
depends on GWT code is actually a GWT user
runs GWT Tooling.
So, we realize that and with that in mind,
let's see if we can speed up the GWT Compiler
for you. So, here's some of the things I recommend
to do. Some of you might already be doing
this but hopefully there's a couple things
in here you haven't thought of.
First, use two modules. So, normally, you
might have a, a, a mod-, a GWT module like
MyProject.gwt.xml. So, create another one
like, MyProjectDev.gwt.xml. And what you're
going to do is one of them is going to be
your full production build, all browsers,
all locales, no debugging, no class metadata,
stripping out everything we can to make it
as small as possible with aggressive optimizations
turned on. The second one is going to be the
Dev build. That's going to have all the logging,
all the debugging, printing mode, no obfuscation,
but it's going to be tied to a single browser
in a single locale. In this case, what I'm
showing is, is I've forced the compilation,
only to compile for Safari, and only to compile
for English. What that does, it limits the
amount of separate executables the compiler
has to compile for.
But, you can do a little bit more. What you
can do is--is you can add this flag called
"-draftCompile" which was added to GWT 2.0.
And if you do this what the compiler does
is it still does some optimizations but it
doesn't run them in a loop. So, the compiler
kind of, when it's doing optimizations, it
does an optimization pass and then it says,
"Well, if anything changed or if it, it got
some kind of gain, let's try it one more time."
And then as the code gets smaller, it says,
"Oh, let's go back through and run this optimization
again." And will keep iterating until it can't
squeeze your application down any more. And
what the -draftCompile says is, "Oh, I'll
do the iteration once." So do a quick optimization
pass, but don't keep going back trying to
find more, squeeze out more and more.
Here's a real world example, I have a large,
relatively large graphing library called "Timescope",
300KB of code on a disk. A production compile
on my MacPro four Core machine takes three
minutes and forty-seven seconds. A Dev compile
with the module I showed you using -draftCompile
takes 42 seconds. Now, 42 seconds, it's still
a lot, right?
We-, we'll try to improve on that but, that's
a relatively, that's a si--, six times, I
don't what it is that, five times, six times,
seven times reduction. It's pretty good. But
for reference, a Dev mode refresh is two seconds,
so, don't do what I'm telling you. Well, do
--do-- it because it does help, but don't
really rely on it. Don't rely on doing full
compiles if Dev mode is available for you.
You'll be lu--, you'll be a lot less irritated.
However, we can go further. It turns out,
a MacPro is four, is two times faster than
a MacBook. Well, why should that be? Well,
I, the one I have at home versus my desktop
mach-, my MacPro is the same CPU, same frequency.
Well, the GWT Compild--, the GWT Compiler
uses multiple threads. So, the more cor--,
cores you have, the faster it's going to be
and it farms those out. So, buy a faster machine
is one thing to do.
[laughs]
If you have a RAID array, the compiler is
relatively Disk I/O hungry, so if have a RAID
array or an SSD drive, it does tend to produce
a benefit. It varies; I've measured it to
be about 50 percent on my machine. 64-bit
Java 6 VM on the Mac, if I enable Dash Server
when I'm running the GWT compiler, I get a
15 percent small, faster compile. And if I
enable 2GB of memory and Dash Server, my compiles
reduce from 42 seconds to 26 seconds. So,
it's going back 42 seconds to 26 seconds.
That's pretty good. So, use -draftCompile,
use Dev module, add more memory, add some
more CPUs, and use Dash Server and you can
double your compile speed.
So, there's one other thing you can do. GWT
has this thing called Generators, some of
you may be aware of it but basically the compiler
can execute a plug-in sort of, of your writing
at compile time and generate code and then
compile it. And this is how GWT RPC works.
If you are willing to go the route of eliminating
RPC and other generator dependant libraries,
the compiler will run faster. But don't do
it unless you really have to because you'll
lose some productivity.
Now, some of you are just a little bit more
impatient and 26 seconds for a compile is
still too much, so if you've got a little
bit of extra money in your pocket and you
got a cluster sitting around in your, in your
home or your place of business or you can
use your, you know you can sort of hack in
to your, your botnet into your co-workers
machines, you can use distributed builds.
So, this was added to GWT but it wasn't really
documented but GWT does have the capability
of farming out the compiles to a cluster.
Now, the components for doing this are there,
but the glue isn't because we don't know what
your internal network is. So, we can't just
write something that's going to distribute
stuff out because how your machines copy,
wha--, what's your network look like, you
got a SAN, network storage, we don't know
that. So you have to write that stuff to marshal
that stuff around. That's the piece you have
to write, but we'll provide all the other
goodies.
So, the first step is, you have to write a
precompile. That's that first phase of the
compiler. So, let's imagine somewhere on your
computer, on, on your corporate network there's
a shared network attached directory called
"work." So, you run this command: java.come.google.dev.gwtdev.Precompile
and you give the name of your GWT module.
And you give it "-work.dir" and this network
attached directory.
So, the GWT Compiler will do that initial
parsing step, take the Java AST and serialize
in to that directory and will run out an extra
file called permCount.txt. What this says
is how many permutations is going to be compiled.
Like if you've got Safari, IE, Opera, and
Firefox is four. If you've got two different
languages, it's two times that so it's eight,
and so on. So, that will tell you how many
permutations the compiler is going to compile.
Which kind of tells you how many machines
you might want to maximally distribute it
to.
The second step is the slowest part of the
compiler. This is distributed; this is called
the CompilePerms part. It's a highly paralizable
part; it's also the part that does most of
the optimizations. So, what we want to do
is, if you have n machines, and you've got
n permutations, so let's say you have eight
machines and you've got eight permutations
to compile. For each machine in your cluster,
we're going to run this command: com.google.gwt.dev.CompilePerms
and we're going to give it the module, the
"hello" module.
You give it the same work.dir you did the
precompile, which is on your network somewhere
and you give it -perms i, where i is one to
eight. So, on the first machine, it's -perms
1 and on the eighth machine in your cluster
it's -perms 8. And that will map to some particular
thing like, English Firefox and Chinese IE,
or whatever; whatever you're compiling for.
If you've got less than the number per-, machines
than the number of permutations, let's say
you have 32 permutations, we only got eight
machines, you have to have some kind of queuing
system that you built yourself, some kind
of script where you, you basically have a
list of the things that have to be built,
the perms have to be built and you dequeue
the one and when your machine is done it,
the next free machine will dequeue the next
one, and so on. But, you guys are really smart
and you'll figure that out.
The final step is after all of the various
permutations have been compiled, you're going
to do a link stage. And what this does is
it compiles all the generated artifacts, all
the JavaScript files, all the sprited images,
all of the HTML files, everything the GWT
Compiler produced and it has to package them
up. And the standard linker is going to package
it for like, war deployment, but I mean there
are other linkers out there people have wrote
deploying on an Android device and things
like that.
There's all kinds of fancy stuff you can do.
And what you do is you run java.com.google.gwt.dev.Link
and you give it the module and again, you
give it the work.dir, you give it war.dir,
which is where it's going to deposit the war
structured application and you give it this
directory called "aux", which is where you
want files that you don't want to serve up
from the war; because the compiler generates
various extra files, like serialization policy
things, the story of your compile, which is
what the compiler did to your code and where
all this, this, what's taking the most amount
of space.
So, you don't want that to be visible to the
user. Now remember, the link phase, like the
precompile phase, executes on a single machine;
that's the serializa-, the serialized part.
I also remember that the work.dir, the gwt.dev.jar,
that has the GWT Compiler in it, the gwt.user.jar
and all your applications source and other
resources have to be network visible because
if you're going to farm this out to all your
machines, they have to be able to see it.
But that's basically it, those three simple
steps and you guys will be building, you know,
doing builds in one or two seconds if you're
fast. So, here's some, here's that live notes
link ag--, again if you want to look at the
Wave where the notes are being taken. I think
it also asks questions there but, I'm ready
to take questions, so if you want to, you
can come up to one of the two mics and I'll
be happy to answer. Thank you.
[applause]
Or I can look at the Wave and somebody already
asked a question.
[pause]
Yes.
>>man1: Yes, could you talk a little bit more
about the linking cycle? You, you mentioned
that, you know, it, it, is that going to like
let you link modules together without necessarily
recompiling all of them in one big go, or,
what, what not, just talk a little bit about
it.
>>Ray: Ok, so the linking cycle is essentially
responsible for a couple things. One is --is--
it generates the bootstrap scripts, or the
.nocache.js script which is different depending
on where you intend to ultimately deploy your
application. So, for example, you know that
there's the cross-site linker, which is if
you've got a GWT application and you want
to sort of source script it from a third party
to a main versus another linker we have called
the iFrame linker where it actually kind of
loads the GWT application up in a, in a hidden
frame.
There are other linkers like there is a gadget
linker. So, if you want to write an iGoogle
gadget using GWT, there's a linker that's
able to structure the code so instead it can
load up to a proxy server in an iGoogle context.
So, but, essentially what the linker is supposed
to do is it gets a list of artifacts, which
are all the compiled JS artifacts, the files
that are related to those, like PNG, sprited
images, CSS that's been optimized or compiled
and things like that. And it basically has
to put them in the right directory so its
free to basically zip them up, put them in
whatever directory structure it wants, and
finally it has to generate the bootstrap code
because since it knows all of the output.js,
it is the one responsible for generating the
nocache.js file which knows which right, correct
permutation to actually load up. So, it will
say, in the script it will say, "If you're
an IE browser, then you have to load up this
particular artifact versus if you're on Firefox
it will load up this particular one." So,
the script does detection, loading, so it
generates the nocache file and it packages,
essentially. Yes?
>>man2: Thank you. You talked earlier about
the obfuscation on the RPC data types. I'm
curious how that works because you're backend
wouldn't know what the obfuscation was.
>>Ray: You know, I'm actually not that, Bob
Walter would know more, exactly how it works.
But I believe that there's a file written
to disk that knows the map between obfuscated
name and the real name so that when it gets
a serialized payload on the server, it will
look up via the obfuscated identifier what
the real Java identifier was.
>>man2: Ok, that makes sense. Thanks.
>>Ray: Ok.
>>man3: Is there any way to avoid a full compile
in run devmode when you change things that
are server i-, in the server packet. I'm sorry,
shared, if you know that the branch of code
isn't going to be affected on the server;
you're just doing front-end, you know, front-end
debugging but it just happens to be a shared
class.
>>Ray: Yeah, that's a good question and we've
heard that a lot and unfortunately there's
no good answer for it because sometimes the,
if you run the server in debug mode, sometimes
the VM can be told to reload a class that's
been modified and sometimes it can't. But
we're working on a couple things to ameliorate
that. We have some people working on what's
called SuperDevmode that sort of tries to
e-, eliminate what the com-, the, tries to
make the refresh in devmode faster from the
aspect of it has to run the generators every
time because if something could have changed
there. And also, to sort of make the server
site reloading happen better. But, I, I can't
give you a, a direct answer for that because
we're still kind of thinking about how best
to do it. But you might want to look at something
called JavaRebel, if you've seen that. It's
a, I believe it's a utility that you can use
that allows you to reload any class at runtime
on the server site. So, I think people use
it to get around the limitations of, they
changed something in Eclipse, this is even,
this is outside of GWT, it's like for any
Java application where they can modify class
and then --they-- they want to reload it and
a lot of times the debugger and codes will
say it can't reload this class. You have to
restart it, restart the server. But I think
Java Rebel allows you to get around that limitation.
>>man3: Do you know if that's, do you know
if that's applicable if you're running under
no server where you have your own deployment
container?
>>Ray: Actually, it would be even more applicable
because then, you'd have more control over
how the, the server gets started if you're
running your own server rather than the devmode
server.
>>man3: The name of that was again, I'm sorry.
>>Ray: It was, I think its Java Rebel, is
the name of it. I could, I could be misremembering,
but--
>>man3: Thank you.
>>man4: I'm curious about turning off the
Java class data, the disabling it?
>>Ray: Yeah.
>>man4: If you're doing it, if I turn that
off and another developer does an instanceof
is it always true, is it always false, or
does it do an error?
>>Ray: It still will be able to do instanceof
correctly because the, the way that GWT implements
instanceof is by this hidden field that it
puts on the prototype of every field that
it called the typeid. The instanceof operator
operates on that. The class metadata is really
just kind of string data that is really for
display purposes and it's not actually, it
doesn't really matter too much to the logic
of implementing the instanceof operator.
>>man4: Do you lose the class, like two string
on the class?
>>Ray: Yeah, if you two string the class instead
of being like, you know, "employee", it would
be like, "class $1" or something like that.
>>man5: You mentioned that the singleton pattern
implemented with the static initializer was
slightly inefficient in, in GWT because of
static initializer--
>>Ray: Yes.
>>man5: What if you use the eNom pattern for
singleton as opposed to a list of constants
because there's that other issue with the
eNom--
>>Ray: Yeah.
>>man5: Which one's better?
>>Ray: It's still inefficient so any time
you have a static field that is initialized
by a static initializer, and an eNom is an
implicit static initializer, it's always there.
However, we do have two optimizations where
they're in a pipeline that both reduce the
cost of static field initializers by tracking
if an, if it, if a, if a initializer has been
called once, then later in the code it won't
call ever again. So, it reduces the amount
of times it's going to check and secondly,
we can, we can a lot of times hoist those
initializations up to the front of the program
so that after the program has been boot strapped,
right, basically no initialization happens
at all. So, there are a lot of things we have
in the pipeline and hope, and I don't want
to encourage people too much to change their
code, only until GWT 2.2 comes out if you're
really desperate, you can look at like changing
fields from static being lazy with it. Thanks.
Ok, I got four minutes left if anybody has
any questions, otherwise, thanks for coming.
Oh, and by the way, advertisement, the next
session you definitely want to stay around
for it, its architecting GWT apps for performance
and it's done by Joel Webber and Adam of the
Wave team. So, you definitely want to stick
around for that because they're going to teach
you a lot of the tricks they use to make Wave
run fast. Thank you.
[applause]